(logo whooshing)
- We're incredibly trained
and incredibly good
at making simple shit complicated
which then fucks us at scale.
(hip-hop music)
What's up, everybody?
Welcome to the refurbished first episode
of the AskGaryVee Show which,
let's call it what it is,
should be a show where
people ask me questions
like it was for the
first 300 episodes or so.
And by the way, Jim, on that note,
let's get at least one AskGaryVee Show
into the Facebook live
recap thing that we do
to see the spikes to put on Instagram.
what a format that was.
What a big shout-out to
Steve Unwin and India
and Stefan and all the other characters
that were part of that show.
D Rock's still here, and so, we're back.
As you now know, my podcast interview show
is now taking two forms
either interrupted by Gary Vee
which I'm actually already rethinking too
because people really get
mad at me for interrupting
and I really need to consider
to try to get better,
then just the audio experience
where I just interview people
'cause that's the mood.
But I'm bringing back the AskGaryVee Show
and here's how it is.
For everybody watching right
now and I know you're watching,
Instagram, what up?
TikTok, what up?
Twitter, what's up?
LinkedIn and Facebook, what is up?
Right this second text
me on my community app,
212-931-5731,
212-931-5731.
Text right now, Zane
is literally in my app
signed in as me right now
looking for your questions,
he's reading 'em, he's gonna
take his favorite questions.
So literally texts me right now
with the question that you have,
he's literally reading 'em
making a subjective call
of which one he likes, I'm
gonna call you right now
and I'm gonna answer
your fucking question,
that's the AskGaryVee Show.
You're gonna ask a question
when i go live randomly,
this is random, I'm live.
Zane most often but somebody
else sometimes as well,
I guess, will read the questions.
Are they coming in, Zane?
- Yep, they're coming in.
- Thank you.
A lot of you don't text me,
haven't signed up for my text platform,
so this is the time, 212-931-5731.
You're starting get some questions?
- Yep.
- You like something you read?
- Yeah.
- Well, fuck it.
Call 'em, dial it.
This is it, this is what we're doing now,
this is where some of the best
content has ever come from,
this is where the most help comes from,
I'm at my strongest
when I answer questions.
Who's this?
- This is Matt from Boston.
- Good.
- Hello?
- Matt, it's Gary Vee,
you're on the AskGaryVee
Show reboot episode one
or maybe not, I don't know
how the team's gonna do it.
How are you?
- [Matt] I'm incredible, how are you?
- Matt, I'm so good, I have good news.
In your Wikipedia one day,
it will say that you were the first caller
on the AskGaryVee reboot episode one show,
what do you think about that?
- [Matt] This is crazy.
I was just watching you on LinkedIn
and I'm like in my car and
I'm like off the parking deck,
so I'm moving my car while
simultaneously talking to you.
- I love it, brother,
what's your question?
- [Matt] So, my question
is, so, I'm currently,
I just recently moved to
New York City back in August
and I've been working as
an executive assistant
at a scaffolding company.
And so, I'm really just trying to get
kind of my feet under me
and find a place to be
because that job recently moved
from Brooklyn to Staten Island
so I'm looking for somewhere else to be.
And so, my question is
how do I stand out in
the interview process?
- I say a couple ways.
Everybody fucks up
interviews 'cause they fake,
'cause they try to conform to the job
instead of tripling down on who they are.
So in a world where everyone's
reverse-engineering the judge
and they're giving answers they think,
you should see people come to me
when they interview with me,
all they do is regurgitate shit
that I've put out on the internet
thinking I'm gonna like it
when I can sense they're full of shit.
- [Matt] Right.
- So, bro, you need to be 100%
you and it's a numbers game,
I don't understand how
people don't understand this.
Send five fucking thousand
resumes on LinkedIn
and Instagram DM to the
5000 places you want to work
AKA the 39 places you wanna work
and every single person
that can make a decision
in those companies.
Bro, this is a great opportunity.
Like if you just move back and
you're in this predicament,
this is your chance to actually take,
how old are you?
- I'm 22.
- Even better.
Bro, what are your three
favorite things in life?
Like sports, wine, you
know, what do you like?
- [Matt] Well, I like
spent like 10 years--
- I don't give a fuck.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
- And I loved it, I loved it.
- Okay, okay.
- [Matt] I loved it.
And the thing is is that I
did that in Massachusetts,
I just moved from
Massachusetts to New York.
- Fuck the Patriots.
- [Matt] And I wanted to get extra hype,
I just graduated college.
I study criminal justice
and psychology, I love that.
I did a lot of nonprofit work,
and so, I was doing things with that.
I love working with kids,
I love those three things.
- Bro, you have to go work
at a UFC training facility.
- Yeah.
- I think.
I mean, you love
psychology, you love kids,
you love mixed martial arts, right?
- [Mat] Yeah, I've trained in Taekwondo
since I was seven and I'm 22 now.
- Bro, don't be a dick,
go into that field.
Being an executive admin for
a fucking scaffolding company
is no different in being an
executive admin right now
at Rumble for Eugene or at
some fucking, I don't know,
like there's probably 700 fucking gyms--
- [Matt] Right, yeah,
and I wasn't happy there
and I left, I just left.
- That's just like--
- [Matt] Full on like,
'cause I just wasn't happy.
I was meeting, working crazy
hours just doing things
that I didn't wanna do.
- Are we talking about
the scaffolding company?
Are we talking about--
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay.
- The scaffolding company.
- Good.
- I left there
because I just didn't like it.
- It sucks.
- [Matt] It was nice it got me here,
I was able to save a little money
so I'm able to kind of
search for the next month.
- And by the way, that saving money thing,
like one of the things
I think a lot about,
yeah, dude, and that month
is gonna go like this
which is why I love side hustles at night.
Like to me, bro, are you living at home
or living with somewhere?
- [Matt] My girlfriend
and I have an apartment
right in Queens, so we're
doing that right now.
- One strategy to think about is
what can you do from 6:00
p.m. to like 10:00 p.m.
as a side hustle or is as bullshit job
just to pay for your rent
and whatever minimal food you
need to eat until you get the?
My biggest concern is
you saved for a month,
now you're holding your breath,
you don't find a good job,
you're gonna take another
bullshit job in two months
'cause you're worried to pay for rent.
This is what everybody
does, they go into a jail.
- [Matt] Right, which is
why I don't wanna also
like just take anything that I can get,
but at the same time,
I had that be my all--
- So you, so you need,
so you need to build a--
- Quit.
- I get it, brother.
So you need a framework
from 6:00 p.m. to 10:00 p.m.
so you can spend 8:00 a.m.
to 6:00 p.m. to get that job.
This is why I love flipping so much,
this is why I love humility
and working at 7-Eleven at
a 24-hour convenience store
and living in a shitty place,
I want people out of the
jail of fucking taking a job
they don't like just to pay
for fucking an apartment
with their girlfriend.
- [Matt] Right, absolutely.
And I think I've got
a lot of like auditing
'cause I've been following
you for probably like
four or five years now,
and I've just kind of
really audited myself
because I was on that kind of like
kick of like wanting
to do something myself,
wanted to do my own thing.
And I'm like realizing, I'm
coming to terms with the fact
that I'm not that person,
I'm the person more so to support the idea
and I feel I'm better at that.
And so,--
- A, I love you for,
I love you for that self-awareness
and it makes me feel so good
because even though I'm the
entrepreneur's entrepreneur,
literally two different people
came to me in Miami this weekend and said,
"My favorite entrepreneur,
"you're their favorite
entrepreneur," you know?
And I was like, "Oh, yeah."
I've seen that stuff like your
athlete's favorite athlete,
I was like, "Oh, shit."
But what I'm so pumped about is
I'm actually putting out content
to make people not be
entrepreneurs when they're not.
I wanna talk about self-awareness,
not entrepreneurship.
I wanna talk about
happiness, not making money.
- [Matt] Absolutely.
- Brother, listen to me.
Figure out a way to make money
from 7:00 p.m. to midnight
whether that's eBay, the flip shit's real.
Or some 24-hour fucking job.
- [Matt] And I'm fine with
waiting tables and doing things--
- I can see, I can hear it in your voice.
So, wait, this is the game.
Do that in parallel with
spending 7:00 a.m. to 6 p.m.
on hitting up every single
person in martial arts
and mixed martial arts that
you could be the admin for.
- [Matt] Well, what if I don't
wanna go down that route?
What if I wanna--
- Let's make another one.
- [Matt] The criminal justice
route and the marketing side
that I've done with work in the past,
I've done nonprofit work--
- Love.
- [Matt] I've done things like that,
and so, I'm trying to get more experience.
- So are we trying to go as literal
as you wanna do the
marketing for a law firm?
- [Matt] Maybe, it's like,
that's what, of course,
I'm doing much in the realm
of like wanting to see things.
- Good.
- That I'm--
- So, here's the good news--
- [Matt] Applying to real estate stuff,
I'm applying to administrative
work in a lot of--
- Why real estate?
- To try to get experience.
Because I had a connection back in Boston,
that, him and I spoke of a lot
for a company here in New York City,
and so, we've been kind
of talking about that--
- Why?
- Contact and applying with--
- Because I think I wanna try.
- Why not?
- Why?
- I'm interested in--
- No, no, no, not why not,
not why not, not why not.
Why not's a shitty answer.
Why?
- Because--
- My concern,
my concern, if I could be transparent,
is you may think there's money in it.
Nothing you said prior got
me excited about real estate.
- [Matt] Okay.
- I could be wrong,
we're just doing the AskGaryVee show here,
but why not is a horrible answer.
And a lot of people
use that as a catch-all
for what they're really saying,
which is this might be
able to make me some money.
Other people have made money
in it, I might wanna do it.
- [Matt] Mm-hm.
Well, I've respected
the guy who spoke to me
and the connection I made
back when I was living in Massachusetts.
And the value that he projected was--
- Nope.
- Being in that position
when people are in the
real estate situation,
when they're trying to
expend on the company itself.
I don't know if, can I
mentioned the company?
- You can do whatever the
fuck you want, go ahead.
- [Matt] Okay, well,
they're basically trying
to redesign the scuminess of the industry
and I've always been a supporter
of trying to, you know,
cut the bullshit out and cut
all that out and be, you know,
the best person in that field.
Whether it's like doing the
good thing for that field,
and so, that's why--
- Look, that's the first seed
of something, where, okay,
you're gonna use a very macro
point of view to justify why.
I respect a lot of people,
I don't wanna do that thing
for the majority of my life.
- [Matt] Right.
- Just 'cause you were--
- Does that go back to like the tasting?
Like if you're like mildly into it,
or do you think that's like
total bullshit because--
- No, no, look, it all
comes down, honestly,
this whole game comes down to
how much humility do you have?
Are you and your girl willing to live
in a even worse apartment
for the next eight years?
And are you willing to work
at 7-Eleven or something,
or wait tables for eight years.
Because tasting sounds fun on paper,
but the way you're talking about it,
is a very structured way,
where you're gonna have to do
everything for a year or two.
So you taste four things in eight years,
whereas if somebody's
really willing to go humble,
doesn't have a significant other,
is willing to live on couches,
they can be rogue as fuck
'cause they have no expenses.
You put yourself in a jail, you have rent.
- [Matt] Right.
- You have a mental jail of
the perception, potentially,
of not being able to afford that rent
and having to live with your
parents or somebody else,
that may look bad to your girl
and/or everybody around you.
You're creating a jail.
- [Matt] Right.
- So that limits your tasting ability
to maybe four things in eight years.
- [Matt] Right.
- Do you have the humility
and patience to step back
at the age of 30 and saying, okay,
I've done criminal justice, real estate,
mixed martial arts and sports cards,
'cause I'm into it and say,
fuck, I don't like any of them.
Do you have the ability
to double down to 35?
That is fucking mental fucking power
that the far majority people don't have.
And I don't wanna impose my
mental prowess on others,
which is why I wanna talk through
this in an articulate way,
to bring as much value to
as many people as possible,
predicated on how I roll.
- [Matt] Right.
- Now, there's a lot of things you can do
with that information.
You can have a conversation
with your girl and say listen,
we need to cut our costs to
zero, how are we gonna do that?
Who's our best friend from
school that now lives here,
can we crash with them?
I have no idea where parents
live or others, older siblings,
like, this is the game
of making it operational.
- [Matt] Right.
- Happiness has to be the ROI, brother.
- [Matt] Absolutely,
and that's why right now
I'm focusing on specifically
looking at places to work.
And I think I'm thinking too long term,
rather than just putting it all out there
and applying to different places.
- Correct, correct.
In a game of no's,
you have to try to get as
many yeses as possible,
you have no options yet.
- [Matt] Right.
- Everybody over thinks it
and they're trying to like.
Here's what happened,
we live in a society
of so much fruitfulness
over the last 30 years and school is fake,
that people think they actually have
more options than they do.
- [Matt] Mm-hm.
- Because the system's
now not in your favor,
it's not telling you what
to do, it's an open slate,
so what you have to do is
fucking spray, not pray,
spray and wait.
If I don't have a job right
this minute, in the world,
I'm applying to a
thousand places in a day.
- [Matt] Right.
- People are fucking
talking to me about, like,
getting a resume together,
I'm like what the fuck
are you talking about?
DM 500 people, LinkedIn 500 people
and really tell them the
truth about who you are.
You have the humility and
strategy, which I think is smart,
to be an admin or a right hand,
the world is your fucking oyster.
I would fucking DM Dana
White and reply, yo,
I will eat shit for 24 months
and close every fucking gap in
your life like a fucking dog
if you give me a shot.
Guess what?
If, God willing, Dana White,
by accident, saw that DM,
on what I just told you to
write, you're getting that job.
- [Matt] Yeah, and then
you do that eight, 500,
thousand times in a week, is
just increasing that chance.
- And you end up on Team Gary Vee.
- [Matt] I applied for it.
- Apply again.
Thank you, brother.
- [Matt] You got it, thank you, Gary.
- God, I love the AskGaryVee show.
(laughs)
There's nothing like it.
- So, then--
- I don't even wanna fucking work anymore.
I think this is just literally
what I wanna do for a living.
Zane, come on,
you need to be a little
bit more on top of it.
That's right, Rob, let's
not have any dead space.
Talk to me about what's
going on on LinkedIn.
Just in general,
observations while we
wait for fucking Zane.
- So, one interesting question
that somebody has been...
We posted a TikTok clip
of the Superbowl commercial.
- Don't hit sent yet.
- But it's not a commercial.
What, that how we were about
to buy a Superbowl commercial,
or like six--
- Oh, yes!
- But you didn't have the money to do it.
- Well, I had the money for the spot,
it was like all my money
and I was gonna do it,
but I didn't know that you had to buy
another 50 million dollars
worth of bullshit television
just to get that opportunity
to buy the Superbowl spot.
- One question that we got
though, in the comments for that,
was like what would your
commercial be today?
Like would it change at all from when--
- It would be right...
I'll do it right now.
If it aired yesterday, America, what's up?
It's Gary Vee.
(clicks tongue)
I want to know you and bring
you as much value as possible,
here's my phone number,
212-931-5731, text me.
Also, here's all my social, follow me.
I talk about self-awareness and happiness
and making it unbelievably practical.
I want to be your friend, America.
I'm Gary Vee.
- [Man] Same as...
- I would say, I guess the same.
- That's the exact same thing.
- Was it?
Yeah, I mean, that's--
- Fully the exact same thing.
- Well then I'm consistent if anything.
All right, let's go, Zane.
Who's this?
- This is Milos in Atlanta.
- All right.
(phone ringing)
- [Man] What about one?
- [Milos] Hello?
- Hello?
- [Milos] Hello, Gary?
- Yes, is this Milos?
- [Milos] Yes, it's Milos, hi.
I'm from Poland, by the way,
so I'm also an emigrant
from the eastern Europe.
- Well, it's very nice to meet
you, my friend, how are you?
- [Milos] I'm very good, how are you?
- Tremendous, what can I help you with?
- [Milos] So, I'm a law
student in Atlanta, Georgia
and I'm pursuing this career
and I've always been
interested in different stuff,
in the films and the media
and public relations,
but I decided to go ahead
and just pursue the legal career, like--
- Why?
- [Milos] You know, like,
'cause my dad wanted to.
I'm not gonna lie, like
that was the reason
'cause, you know, I thought
that was a stable profession
and, you know, I had some
interest politics or whatever.
But now I'm here and man, I'm...
I don't know, I just...
I don't know this is the thing I wanna do.
- No shit, of course it's not.
You did it 'cause your dad wanted you to.
- [Milos] Right.
- Is your dad in Poland?
- [Milos] Yeah, he's in Poland.
- Perfect.
(laughs)
So, just tell your dad you're doing it
and do something else.
- [Milos] Sorry, what was that?
- Well, I think you
should do something else.
- [Milos] Oh, yeah, so my idea was...
Right now, I was thinking--
- Kidding, not kidding.
- Maybe I should just...
Yeah, I was thinking I should just apply
to different entertainment companies
and just work there as some,
you know, in a legal position.
- Milos, I like what you're doing.
'Cause I was joking a little
bit about the dad thing,
but not really, I mean, it was a hot tape,
but we need to talk here a little bit.
But I like the idea of leveraging
what you've already invested in.
How long have you been in law school?
- [Milos] It's my first
year inside this company,
this is my first semester.
- So, look, the beauty
is you're in Atlanta,
which is becoming the new Hollywood.
So there's a ton going on.
It's...
There is potential if
you apply to 200 places,
for somebody wanting to
give you an internship
or a low paying job for the summer,
or full-time if you can handle the both
and eastern block kids tend to be able
to handle both things
'cause they're not fancy.
And I think it's a great idea
to leverage what you've
already invested in
to get in the door,
and then once you're the junior
man in the legal department,
you start working the halls of the agents
and the creative people and
you start shooting the shit,
and over time, no question
can you go from a legal path
to maybe being a strategist or a creative,
if you have that natural talent.
- [Milos] Exactly, that was my plan.
My only...
So, what would you recommend I do?
- Apply to every single
entertainment company in Atlanta,
on LinkedIn, their website
or DMing the founder.
- [Milos] Okay, what do you think
about the clients to bring their media?
- Well, we're not looking
for anybody illegal.
- [Milos] Okay.
All right.
- Are you looking to move?
- [Milos] Oh, yeah, I'm,
you know, I'm an immigrant
so I really have like one
place here, I'm just...
I was looking whatever I can--
- But aren't you going to school?
Like won't you have to go back?
Like aren't you in law school?
- [Milos] Yeah, I'm in law school.
- So if I said yes, you would come up here
and transfer to a different law school?
- [Milos] Yeah, if I could get a job there
and work for you, then yeah.
- Well, all right, just
email me, gary@vaynermedia,
and I mean, an entry legal job here,
I'm not sure what that
pays versus the balance
of like how much that takes
away from your studies,
but you can email me.
But let me tell you right now,
and in the title, put Polish
kid looking for a legal job,
but I'm telling you right now,
Atlanta is fucking loaded if
you care about entertainment.
- [Milos] Okay, well, beside
from just applying to places,
do you think I should
also just hit up people
and try to network and call them and--
- Yes, that's what I said.
I said apply on LinkedIn and their website
and then DM the founders on the Instagram.
- [Milos] Okay.
- Do you like hip-hop music?
- [Milos] Yeah, I actually
just do rap is all I'm,
like I actually was
doing concerts and stuff.
- Can you rap right now
for me a little bit?
- [Milos] Let's see.
- Do you need a beat?
- [Milos] No, I got it, I got it.
(rapping in foreign language)
Damn, I'm too stressed out right now.
- I get it though.
- [Milos] I'm just like
in shock you called me.
- I get it.
Everything's stressful in life.
- [Milos] But yeah, thank you
very much for calling me and--
- Listen to me, listen to me.
If you love hip-hop and you're in Atlanta
and you got some legal ability,
but you're also eastern European rugged,
I promise you the south side
of Atlanta will fuck with you.
I would hit up the best entrepreneurs,
whether they're Jeezy or 2 Chainz,
bro, it's the same advice to everybody.
When you are dreaming
of being in something,
the entryway is either
praying through resume
or hitting up decision-makers
that love humility and bravado.
- [Milos] Right.
- Like the last kid that
just called, Dana White,
the same thing for 2 Chainz
and Jeezy and Coach K,
you understand?
- Yeah.
- Go execute.
- Could I ask you
one more thing?
- Real fast.
- [Milos] Okay, so I also started
'cause I was thinking about getting...
I listened to your book, "Crushing It."
- Yes.
- And I was thinking,
okay, I'm a law student,
I'm interested in media, I
wanna get myself out there.
So I started my English
website, I mean, Facebook,
and Polish Facebook about
my name, Milos Alberkey,
American law blog and also in Polish,
and I'm very active.
Just to talk about what's
going on in the United States
and actually also scheduled a talk
just with one of my
distinguished law professors,
what do you think about
that to also get noticed?
- You should you should do that every day,
multiple times a day.
- [Milos] Okay.
- Go get 'em, Milos.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Let's keep it going.
What else?
D Rock, what do you got in this--
- [D Rock] Right now, I'm blank.
- Come on, Dust.
- That I like?
- [Gary] Yes!
How was Superbowl, anything good?
- Yeah, it's been cool I think.
- [Gary] Good, what do you...
I see you got something.
- No, yeah, I tweeted out
that quote that you said.
"You have no right way
and there's your way."
- [Gary] Yep.
- And I think a lot of that applies
to what's going on right now, like,
everyone is trying to be in something,
but then they're not willing to try other,
different avenues to get into it.
Or they think there's one path to it,
versus like, oh no, you should go and like
literally be the assistant
and then work your way up,
like Tyler.
- It's called entitlement.
It's called entitlement.
People think 'cause they
invested in a degree
that that application with the resume
is what the ROI of that was,
'cause they don't realize that that degree
almost means nothing to
87% of the actual world.
There are absolutely degrees
that are ROI positive.
You go to a huge brand
like Harvard and Stanford,
I promise you, Goldman Sachs and VC firms
and other people are gonna look at it.
The problem is there's
about 15 to 25 schools
and about 15 to 25 professions
that that works for
and then there's the rest of us.
And the rest of us used to win in 1983,
because that 15 and 15
was actually 150 and 150.
And what I mean by that is
what you're talking about
is the lack of humility from the masses
to do something they love, right?
It's like John right next to you, right?
Like he got in and even was
thinking about moving quickly,
'cause he thought he had the equity,
until he was enlightened.
And he was like fuck, wait a minute,
there's a lot more equity.
- Well, that's another thing.
I think there's needs
to be more education,
like what we're doing in here,
we're educating more people
and there is a weight about that.
I think when you brought up the educations
all through your school, this is the way,
versus oh no, there are
9000 ways to get it.
- I agree.
We haven't calibrated the internet.
- [D Rock] Right, we haven't.
- You couldn't DM fucking
Dana White in 1987.
And he actually sees it and
he actually might consider it,
'cause there's so many
more entrepreneurial
weird characters making decisions.
- [D Rock] Well, also, when you DM him--
- [Gary] It was also the judge.
And even if he have the internet in '84,
but everybody was still
the decision-makers,
they were going through
a corporate, robotic,
if I don't see this college
on the resume, you're out.
- But I think a lot of
people DM Dana White
and not and he won't respond--
- Because they're like
Dana, give me a job.
- [D Rock] But then they're
also the nine people around Dana
that you could DM--
- 100%.
You were more likely to respond than me,
and now because you're
so fucking big time,
now, seriously though,
you were responding to
everybody, I'm sure, at first
'cause it was fucking cool,
just like I responded every single
fucking human for six years.
I replied to every single
email from 2007 to 2011,
four years, every tweet,
four years, all of that.
I still get anxiety when people write,
"Gary doesn't text me back," now!
This is the best show.
Yeah, I don't even wanna fuck,
don't bring me a fucking guest ever again.
(laughs)
Interrupted, canceled, audio canceled,
only on AskGaryVee, it's the
best show, it's the most value.
Tell me if I'm right.
- Hello?
- Jackie.
- Jackie, it's Gary Vee.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah.
- Gary?
- Yes, Jackie.
- Oh my God.
Yes.
- Uh-huh.
- [Jackie] I just hung up
my boss to answer your call
'cause I knew it was you.
- Best decision ever.
(laughs)
- [Jackie] That's okay,
I will make a, thank you,
but oh my God, I'm so
happy to talk with you.
How are you feeling today?
- So well, where are
you from and what's up?
- [Jackie] I am from Texas,
so I'm a Texas southern girl
but I'm up in Seattle.
- Love it.
What's cooking, Jack?
- [Jackie] So, my question, oh my God,
can't believe I'm talking
to you, this is awesome.
So my question is I have a corporate job
but I have finally said I do
my hustle when I get home,
I wake up extra early,
and you know, do all
of that and everything.
But I'm wanting to start documenting
and like putting out the videos
and I've even been
starting filming the videos
but I don't wanna upload
those 'cause I'm afraid that,
because my job does keep tabs on me
'cause like I even started
like my Airbnb business
and rental arbitrage and everything
and I started promoting
that and they caught on
and they were like,
"Hey, is this cutting into
your time like at your job?"
And I was like, "No,
it's not, of course not.
"It's very casual."
Like really like I'm
hustling from a meeting
and going to make sure
like I've got my stuff ready for my guests
and then I'm going back--
- Jackie, I love it.
It comes down to the job, right?
There's fuckers in this room
that I know were doing shit on the side
while they're supposed to
be, and they work hard,
let alone what's going on at Vayner
that work more standard hours
and they're doing their own side shit,
and I'm cool with it.
We did have to put in a side hustle policy
because we became vulnerable
'cause so many people were doing shit
that some of our client contracts
were like, I was actually.
But I wasn't mad that like
Sid was working on something
for an hour that was, you know,
and so, the reality is you may...
Here's my big thing, get out of jails.
The theme of today is get out
of jails, self-imposed jails.
Kid number one has a rent
that he has to pay with his girl at 22
that I'm concerned is
too expensive, right?
- [Jackie] Yeah, I heard that.
- You most likely can get
another job in your field
that may be more open to
you working after work
on your stuff and don't have cynicism
and quick trigger blame
and thinking that you're
working on their side.
My dad doesn't want Wine Library employees
to actually have their
phone on them in the store
because he's scared that in their hours
that they work in a store,
they're not gonna work
for even two minutes
when they're looking at
their phone, that's my dad.
I, on the other hand,
have no idea what the fuck anyone's doing.
(Jackie laughs)
- [Jackie] Well, yeah, yeah, I get that.
So I get the get out of jail thing.
In my case, it's just like this,
I don't wanna leave this job because--
- Because?
- [Jackie] It's flexible.
- So don't do your side stuff.
- But it's flexible.
- Yeah.
So don't do your side stuff
'cause there's gonna be scrutiny
or go to the tippy-top and say
I work my face off every
minute while I'm here,
know that I'm doing stuff when I get home
instead of watching Netflix.
Being in between and guessing--
- Okay.
- Is gonna keep you in fear.
You only have one or two options, Jack.
Jackie, this is what's
so awesome about life
once you get into a binary framework.
You either have the I'm
gonna get another job
and I'm gonna tell them up front
that I work from 6:00 p.m. on,
so just know what you're
getting into with Jackie,
I'm fucking Jackie and this is how I go.
Or you go to the tippy-top in your place
that you like right now and say
hey, I know that this has flared up before
when I was doing the Airbnb thing,
look at my face, I'm Jackie,
from nine to five, I work every minute.
When I go home, I work also.
- [Jackie] Yeah, that's true.
- If, if, if--
- [Jackie] Make things
so simple and like...
- Everything is, my lack of
education and my lack of fear
is the reason I'm so
successful in business.
I only have simple, I'm only simple
'cause it's actually simple,
we're incredibly trained
and incredibly good
at making simple shit complicated
which then fucks us at scale.
- [Jackie] Oh, yeah, that was like,
yeah, I've been like thinking about this,
like just stressing
out a bit over it but--
- It's that simple.
And if you're my sister, I'm like,
okay, and before you go
have that conversation
with the top telling them what you do,
let's go take 15 interviews
and have two jobs lined up
in case they look you in
the face and say fuck you.
- [Jackie] Yeah, yeah,
that's good, that's good.
I'm gonna do that, I'm gonna do that.
- Jackie, email me when you do it
and tell me how it worked out.
- [Jackie] Okay, yeah, I will, thank you.
- You're welcome, Jack.
Have a great day.
- All right,
have a good one, guys.
- You too, bye-bye.
- [Jackie] You too.
- Keep it moving.
Best show ever.
Single best show on the internet.
- All right, this is Scott.
- How's the reaction?
How are people feeling?
(phone ringing)
- [D Rock] Loving it.
- JR?
Who's this?
- Scott in Arizona.
- [Scott] Hello?
- Hello, Scott.
- [Scott] Hey, Gary, how are you?
- I'm tremendous, how are you?
- [Scott] This is gonna be
great to show my dad later.
- I can't wait.
- [Scott] So my question
to you pertains to my dad,
we're starting to do some work together,
and so, we're gonna be working
in real estate together
and we're both kinda aren't
having any strong will,
have a lot of opinions and ideas.
And my biggest fear is that
we get into an argument
or a disagreement and it kind
of ruins the relationship.
- That'd suck.
- [Scott] I love my dad
to the end of the world,
he's an amazing guy and I
know you worked with your dad
for many years, so what kind
of advice could you give me
to make sure we're
maintaining that relationship
and that constant dialogue?
- I got a lot of opinions
and thoughts and observations
and I hope it brings you value,
so let's start with a
couple more questions.
Have either of you done
real estate before?
- [Scott] So I've been
working in vacation rentals
for the last two years.
We're moving more towards
commercial real estate
at the moment but I'm pretty
well-versed in residential
for what I need.
- And what about your dad?
- [Scott] He's pretty new to a lot of it.
- So he's not from this world?
- No.
- Okay.
- [Scott] He's from consumer
electronics and distribution.
- Why is your dad and
you going into business?
- [Scott] We realized that
we've got a lot of talents
that we each don't have.
So I have the energy, I have the hustle,
I have the ability to do operations,
and he's incredibly good with the numbers,
marketing and sales.
So--
- Like it.
- [Scott] We kinda have
those two different dynamics.
- Love it.
- [Scott] And also, yeah,
he's got that old school,
I've got the new school.
- Next question, family
businesses break down
to two major data points of contention.
One, money, two, respect.
Do you have a sense, if I said to you,
there's a 100% to allocate
and one bucket is money
and the other one is credit,
the credit for being good,
the credit for being better,
what would you say your DNA is?
And then what is your guess on your dad
between money and respect
and being right and credit?
Let's start with you.
- I would say--
- What are you, as a human,
when it comes to money
and credit, the credit?
- [Scott] Right now, I would have money,
I would say 25 to 40% on
money and the rest credit.
- Awesome, what about your dad?
- [Scott] Know I can do a lot--
- No worries, no worries.
- [Scott] My dad, oh, yeah, no,
I'd like the money to be
able to do what I want
and have the freedom and ability,
but the credit is very important.
And then for my dad, a good point,
it's all credit, he wants--
- You guys--
- I wanna make sure--
- You, you guys--
- [Scott] Rest of the world
knows I'm still alive.
- You guys are very vulnerable.
If you're 60, if you're 55 to 75% credit
and he's 100% credit,
you two are wildly vulnerable.
- [Scott] Okay.
- Because in a world where it's gray,
you're both gonna be
fighting for the credit,
for the growth and the results.
Let me tell you why I'm telling you this.
Me and AJ, me and my dad,
my two experiences over the last 22 years.
Me and my dad, my dad on credit and money,
I would argue, is 20% money, 80% credit,
maybe, yeah, 20, 80.
I would say that I'm five and 95.
Problems, we overlapped a
lot, fighting a lot, right?
Me and AJ, I'm 5% money, 95% credit,
AJ is 95% money, 5% credit.
Great team, awesome, everybody won.
This is the family business framework,
people don't speak about it properly,
they don't understand that
it's money and credit,
and the best family
businesses overlap in a way
where one values credit more
than money and vice versa,
thus everyone's scratching their itch.
There'll be resentment 10
years later on both sides,
one would want a little more credit,
the other wishes they
got a little more money,
but they're still breathing
and living successfully.
If you and your dad overlap that much,
you must sit down and
have dinner with him,
show him this video and
speak ad nauseam what happens
when you fight over credit
and you guys take a step back,
have a safe word that stops the fight
and then you take a breath and have dinner
and talk it through.
Communication is the
only prayer for you guys.
- [Scott] I gotcha, that's how--
- My relationship--
- How much I'm in it.
- My relationship with my,
my relationship with my dad and my brother
has never been and can never be the same
since we went into business,
not pro or con, just truth.
Your relationship with your
dad will never be the same
after you entered into
this business together.
- [Scott] Do you enjoy
working with your family?
- Yes but as the driver of
both the money and the credit,
having to give up one in both
scenarios wasn't delicious.
- [Scott] Gotcha.
I appreciate it.
- I appreciate you, brother,
I wish you a lot of success.
I hope you rewatch this
and really internalize it
and I really thank you
for the credit question
because you asked it of me during a time
where I have more
clarity on this than ever
because I don't just have my experience,
I now have the benefit
of seven years of reading
5000 different, 15,000
different interactions
and observing at scale.
- [Scott] Yeah, I've read
the "#AskGaryVee" book
and you had a whole chapter on
it and it was fantastic, so.
- I'll be honest with you.
I've been struggling
coming up with my next book
and I think it might be time for me
to talk about family business.
- [Scott] You're gonna incorporate
that with the perfect timing too?
- That I'm gonna wait
for a little bit longer
as you know I've thrown
that out in the world
for a long time, I think that's
still a work in progress,
but I think it might be
time for family business
because I don't have a
family business dynamic
in front of me for at
least another 15 years
before my children get
of age to even debate it,
so I think I might be ready.
- [Scott] Well, I'll be
the first one to get a copy
when you do.
- 11 copies, brother.
(laughs)
- All right, sounds good.
- Have a great day.
That's some good shit right there.
That's some real good shit right there.
You know why we have to do this improv?
Like just go live and do it
is because when my energy's right,
like I'll cancel shit if my energy's right
and move it around 'cause when
my energy is this zoned in,
like it just extract,
Q&A extracts much more
thoughtful understanding from me.
(phone ringing)
You know?
This is where I'm at my best
'cause I'm forced to go deeper,
whereas when I'm talking in general,
I have to go broad by nature
to bring the most value, you know?
You know, so when I
think about my Instagram
or things that nature,
I'm trying to bring as much value
to as many people as possible
but it can't be as specific
when I have time to breathe
and I get a very specific
question, I can go deeper.
I know that we just
literally helped three people
who are gonna treat, not,
and it may seem to many
that are just watching they
are not in their situation,
oh, wait, I'm not gonna
do it, it's not that,
it's going into it with eyes wide open.
It actually may lead
to more people doing it
'cause they're going in eyes wide open
'cause everyone's scared
to fuck up the relationship
if they love them.
- [D Rock] Again, I
think we've got a caller.
(phone ringing)
- But I've had a million conversation,
the other person doesn't have
the ability to reciprocate.
You can talk to your mom,
she can go a year without--
- [Hannah] Hello?
- And then you have to
know what to do with that,
so it's both.
Hello, I'll be with you in a second.
- Hannah.
- Hannah,
I'll be with you in one second,
I'm just talking with D Rock, okay?
- [Hannah] Oh my God.
- Yep, so as you know, I
mean, we talked about this
a lot at Vayner, I've had
the conversations in candor,
people they yes me and
then they act different.
So it's arming the person to
know what the patterns are
and giving them the
confidence to jump out.
I've been in two family businesses,
I'm not an either right now.
- [Hannah] Oh my God.
- Hi, Hannah.
- Hi!
- How are you?
- [Hannah] I am doing
so great, how are you?
- I'm super well, where are you from?
- Texas.
- What part?
- [Hannah] I live about
25 minutes east of Dallas.
- I love it, give me one second.
Everybody who's watching--
- Okay.
- If you want this oh my
God moment like Hannah has,
212-931-5731, text me.
If you've never signed
up for my text platform,
you'll get an automated reply,
you just gotta get the
contact card into your phone
and locked in because we don't wanna spam,
and boom, you're off to the races.
Oh, Jim, how did the
text we sent a week ago
to let people go into
little different buckets
so that they--
- It was great.
- Great, what were the top hashtags?
- This one right here.
- The ask--
- AskGaryVee and hands down--
- Then?
How many people went into Wine?
- We've got--
- Oh, by the way,
preview, 'cause a lot of
people are watching right now,
and I know this later
and a lot people are
gonna be pumped about it,
if you love wine...
Actually, let me start that sentence over.
If you don't love wine, but
you love how I roll and think
and you wanna support my dad,
if you also like high-end
or medium-end Trader Joe's
to like Wegmans to like
specialty gourmet food,
something's brewing and it's good.
It's real fucking good and look
for that announcement soon.
So if you eat and you can afford stuff
that's of higher quality,
but you love premium products
at ridiculous prices,
I am entering your world
which will give a ton of people under 21
the first time to be able
to do something with me
which is very exciting.
Hannah?
- Oh my God, yeah?
Hi.
- What is your question, darling?
- [Hannah] I guess I can
only get that one, huh?
- Well, if you go fucking fast as shit,
maybe we can get a ton.
- [Hannah] Well then,
give me just a second,
let me go back to my list
'cause I legit can't
think straight right now.
- Okay, go to your list and read them all
and then I will play Plinko board
and answer as many as I can.
- Sounds great.
Okay, first question, how
do you go about streamlining
to make yourself more efficient?
Second question--
- Wait, let me start right there,
I can answer you very quick.
That one's easy, if you
don't judge yourself
for being inefficient,
you become efficient.
I might be one of the most
inefficient people of all time
but because I don't judge it,
I actually become remarkably efficient.
If people realize they
spend more time dwelling
on being inefficient than
actually the efficient work,
everything would change.
- [Hannah] I never thought
of it that way before.
- No shit, that's why you asked it first.
- [Hannah] Well, there you go.
(laughs)
- Hannah, I'm being
really serious with you,
I'm gonna sit on this one
for it's gonna help a lot of people,
everybody judges themselves arbitrarily,
all of a sudden,
everybody thinks they're
an efficiency expert
on them own selves.
All you're doing is
driving home insecurities
and judgment on yourself on
something that doesn't matter.
Doesn't mean try not to get more efficient
but just doing what you can,
like having a calendar
and doing the best you can
is just fine,
the second you don't get to
something on your calendar,
you beat yourself up, is a
second you're inefficient.
- Mm-hm.
- You're macro inefficient.
- [Hannah] Mm-hm.
That makes sense, that
makes a lot of sense.
- I mean, you can't...
Like I was supposed to be
in Singapore right now,
but coronavirus came out,
I decided not to go, right,
'cause of angst at the kids and mom level,
I was like fuck it, I'll stay.
Now I'm here and we, a
couple things have happened
where I have a been
bunch of pockets of time,
I just sat with the admins this morning
and we're scrambling to like
make it efficient as possible.
We should have a great system in place
where we absolutely know
what my 43 priorities are
but we don't, but we kinda do
and it's kind of in my head,
it's kinda in their head.
And over the next 48 hours,
I'm either gonna make it really efficient,
high impact on the time I had or not,
but on Wednesday morning,
whether we did or didn't,
I'm not gonna give a
fuck 'cause it's over.
- [Hannah] Mm-hm.
- The dwelling that
people put on themselves
around efficiency is overwhelming to me
and ludicrous at best
and dangerous at worst.
- [Hannah] Mm-hm.
- Next?
- [Hannah] That makes a lot of sense,
thank you for that.
- You're welcome.
- [Hannah] Okay, let me check my list.
Okay, maybe, actually,
I'm gonna skip around,
following up that question,
what advice could you give
for a recovering adult
who was always told they
were special as a child
that now realize that overall,
they're really just normal or average?
- By being pumped as fuck
about being a human being.
- Mm-hm.
- Perspective.
I'm with you, listen,
you know you're asking me
a hot-button topic for me question
'cause you know my stuff, that's okay.
A, eliminate all anger or
resentment at your parents,
eliminate all of it.
- [Hannah] I have no
anger towards my parents.
My parents gave me the best life.
- I'm not even...
99% of people have that
problem, so since you don't,
let's move on to the next one.
- Okay.
- Number two within this answer.
The who-gives-a-fuck framework.
- Okay.
- Like what does that mean?
Like so you're not special?
Yes, you are, and no, you aren't.
Like in a lot of ways, Beyonce is special,
and in a lot of ways, she's not.
- [Hannah] Mm-hm.
- A lot of ways, Hannah is,
a lot of ways, you're not.
And who's judging the specialness?
What confirmation, affirmation
are you looking for?
Actually, how about let's
play this game, Hannah.
Why can't you be special?
Let's play it a different way,
let's play pretend you are instead of not.
Don't be delusional.
You know, that's not asking
you to be delusional.
Like the you can be anything
you want, is not real, you can.
You cannot be a world-class
rapper or skier or painter
if you want to if you do
not have natural talent
to make you the best in the world.
- [Hannah] Right.
- However, you could go
after all three of those
if you're willing to
be happy that you did.
- [Hannah] Mm-hm.
- You could.
- [Hannah] Yeah, I guess that's true.
- I know it's true.
I don't think we spend enough time,
we put fucking Zucks and Elon Musk
and fucking Meg Whitman on pedestals,
why don't we start putting
Sally who's a ski instructor
who makes 49K a year, because at 13,
she decided she loves skiing,
had the humility at 16 to realize
she's not going to the Olympics,
but then realized happiness
was the only way to actually
live your fucking life
and move to Aspen and
started from the bottom
and got to a $63,000 a year
job being a ski instructor
at a tier three ski place
and lives by her means
and is happy as fuck
every day of her life,
why can't we put her
on a fucking pedestal?
- [Hannah] Maybe because
our self-image is so low
and she's just more
relatable than Elon Musk,
so Elon Musk instantly becomes cooler.
- Of course, but that's our
insecurities manifesting,
fuck those.
- Right.
My husband doesn't believe
I'm actually on the phone with
you, he's sitting next to me.
- What's his name?
- His name's Daniel.
- Hey, Daniel.
- What's up?
- What's up, bro?
It's really me, bro, this
is not an automated message.
- [Daniel] It sounds like you.
- It's really me, bro, I promise.
- That's cool.
- It is cool, you're cool.
(Hannah laughs)
- [Hannah] He's a horseshoer.
- Fucking that fires me the fuck up.
(Hannah laughs)
It does, I love...
Daniel, do you love horseshoeing?
- [Daniel] What's that?
- [Hannah] He asked if
you love horseshoeing?
- I do.
- My man.
- [Daniel] I love making a list by myself
in the great United States of America.
- And I love you for that, brother.
Hannah?
- [Hannah] Yes?
- What else you got?
- Okay.
Okay, what tales do you
have that clue you in
to needing to rest or recharge?
And going off of that,
how you maximize resting
to be able to hit the
ground running right after?
- Great question.
People are very good at lying
to themselves, I try not to,
and when I feel tired, I sleep.
- [Hannah] That's fair.
- It's simple as that.
- Yeah.
- And I'm programmed
and I've got tons of
responsibilities and I hack,
I look at what's in
front of me and I hack,
I figure it out at all cost.
In your example, you look
at good-looking Daniel
and say motherfucker, tomorrow morning,
I'm sleeping till 11:00 a.m., see ya.
- [Hannah] Uh-huh.
Yeah.
So what about, okay, so,
maybe not like physical rest,
what about like mental rest?
Like bouncing back from like--
- Adversity?
Yeah, look, I think
this is about gratitude,
this is why I push it so hard.
- Okay.
- Right?
Even my last answer was self-awareness,
some people are like I don't
even know what's happening,
I'm like I understand,
let's keep focusing on self-awareness.
Like I'm able to bounce back
from everything and anything
'cause I'm grateful.
- [Hannah] Right.
- You're gonna tell me what went wrong,
I'm gonna tell you what
went right, you're alive.
You will never beat me in a debate.
- [Hannah] I do believe that.
- Well, good, then you should be...
I don't know if you believe that
if you're asking the question,
because if you believe that,
you 100% have the capability
100% of time to bounce back.
- [Hannah] Mm-hm.
Yeah, I think it was just like, you know,
we spent a year like pushing
ourselves into the ground
like grinding--
- Yep.
- [Hannah] But it seems
like we didn't understand
that like we need to stop to rest.
- Yep.
- And so, that ended up
as, at the end of, you
know, that 12 months,
we were so burned out,
we were like the most miserable
people you've ever met.
- Do you know why, Hannah?
- [Hannah] Because we
weren't grateful enough?
- Nope, because you
weren't patient enough.
- [Hannah] Oh.
- See, I have a lot of
natural energy and I go hard,
but because I think
about life in a 54-year,
a 73-year window, a 94-year window,
I don't think about it in one-year terms.
Hannah, do you know the
number one thing I do
that disappoints my fan base,
my friends, my community,
the people that like me?
The number one thing,
do you know what the number one thing I do
that disappoints the shit out of them?
Sheerly, when I deliver the
sentence, I can watch their face
go from excitement and
admiration to disappointment,
do you know what that is?
- [Hannah] No.
- It's when I tell them I'm
gonna buy the Jets in 31 years,
not next year.
- [Hannah] Oh, time, they
want it now, not later.
- So did you.
- [Hannah] Oh, wow, frick.
- Frick is right, and we
say fuck in these parets.
The reason you got there was
because you actually did,
people don't get it,
they see me going hard,
that's fueled by gratitude,
most people are fueled
by lack of patience.
The reason I never will burn
out is because I don't allow it
because I'm too patient and too grateful.
If I wanted the Jets next year,
I would start doing manic energy shit
that would lead me to burnout.
- [Hannah] Yeah.
- I love the process,
not the things that I
get out of my process.
- [Hannah] So you already mentally know
that you're playing a long game?
- I'm actually not even that
interested in buying the Jets,
I'm interested in the game
of trying to buy the Jets,
which allows me to never actually burn out
or not have resentment
or pain when I am 89
and it becomes wildly aware to
me that I can't buy the Jets.
- [Hannah] Mm-hm.
- I'm not in it for the million dollars,
I'm not in it for the Jets,
I'm in it for feeling
great about my process,
leaving good along the way
that leads to admiration
and a reputation and respect and legacy
and having fun every day along the way.
If I wasn't gonna do that,
if I didn't care about that,
I would never go to a sports
car show for an entire week
in the last week of July
because that's not gonna be ROI positive.
Through the years over the last decade,
so many people judge me for
my behaviors, they're like,
"That's not gonna help him get the Jets,
"that's not gonna help him get the Jets,
"that's not gonna help him get the Jets,"
'cause they're not listening to me.
Just 'cause I have a
professional business goal,
doesn't mean that I'm
anxious or disappointed
if it doesn't happen, I love the game.
People get burned out
because they want it too fast
or they care about other
people watching them.
I'd be burned out everyday
if I took in the judgment
of the outside audience.
Yesterday, 90% of the advertising industry
was making fun of me on Twitter
because they made a subjective call
on our three Superbowl commercials.
- [Hannah] Mm-hm.
- If I took that to
heart, I'd be upset today.
Instead, I'm happy as fuck
because their opinions don't matter,
the business results do.
- [Hannah] Right.
Oh, heck.
- Good, we're moving up
the ranks, I like this.
We went from frick to
heck, let me keep talking,
I might get you to fuck.
(Hannah laughs)
- [Hannah] Okay, can I
ask you another question?
- I have to go 'cause my
admins are staring at me
in an evil way, but I love you
and I hope you rewatch this
and really understand
what we're talking about.
- [Hannah] Okay, no, I absolutely will,
and I really, really
appreciate your time first.
- Thank you, Hannah, have a great day,
and tell Daniel I love him give him,
give him a big kiss in the mouth for me.
- [Hannah] I can do that.
(Hannah laughs)
- I love it.
Take care, Hannah, bye-bye.
That's the AskGaryVee
show, we're fucking back!
(hip-hop music)